[Music]
come in and wait hey what's up you guys
it's sunday yeah okay everybody's funny
because as soon as we start streaming
they all start [ __ ] piling in there
well yeah because everybody knows that
like you just have to we haven't been in
the waiting room for five yeah
yeah they're all in the waiting room for
five minutes
which i don't know i don't know if we
have to keep doing that that was your
idea not my idea well it's good to let
everybody kind of back up a little bit
most most shows do it because if you
just start streaming immediately you'll
only have like one person and then
everybody will show up and be like hey
yeah yeah and then they all start coming
in so i mean but we always stream at the
same time though yeah it's just like at
six o'clock it's not like we're just
like bursting and surprising everybody
like hey yes we don't usually do that
kind of stuff
but yeah
so uh yeah it's sunday and as i promised
or maybe threatened is a better word
[Laughter]
we watched uh rawhead rex the other day
and uh so we decided we were going to
talk about it because i can't believe we
haven't covered this movie i've seen it
many times saw it when it came out i
have as well i'm not sure how i manage
that because the movie well the thing
about it okay
so the movie it's not good okay can we
agree on that it's not a good movie uh
but
but
it's still like pretty [ __ ] no it's a
good movie no it's good it's it's it's
entertaining in how ridiculous it is
it's good
for what it is it's made up out of
nothing
basically pretty much yeah
we saw it when it came out grant there's
no he sought to he wasn't with us but we
were going to high school together and
me
steve steve and [ __ ] jace jason we
rented this [ __ ] from [ __ ]
blockbuster i think
you're there
hollywood hollywood video one of the two
hollywood all the [ __ ] all the spicy
[ __ ] was over in hollywood
and that was called hollywood i think
that was another that was the competing
the yeah the the the sign was ready i
don't think we had one we had a
blockbuster later and then we had a
movie gallery yeah
but we might have got this one from
hollywood
hollywood theater i think there were
hollywood movies or hollywood video it
was hot something like that was the name
of it grafter's surprise remember he
probably remembers what grantham said in
1986 you saw it at the showboat in
riverview he asked
yeah i think that's right did you see it
in the theater or did you like rent it i
did not see it saw it in the theater
first and then we rented it i'm pretty
sure i think we've [ __ ] both i think
no no no no
no
we rented it first
i think we rented it
because showboat was reruns
and and [ __ ] that wasn't the show but
was a privately owned theater
and uh maybe they showed it there but i
don't think we saw it there we i'm
pretty sure we rented it
and it was new
i think it was released almost directly
to video wasn't it
no i'm pretty sure it got a theatrical
relationship release yeah
well showboat got it shobo got it like a
couple weeks after it had left the other
theaters
yeah we had theaters like that just like
that right it was like a buck it was
like a buck back in back in the early
90s you go see [ __ ] for like a buck
after like a month or two
was a dollar theater
yeah and my buddy mike worked there
he [ __ ] swept it up it's all torn
down now though
but uh no we saw it
and we liked it
we liked it was
all right we were goofing on a little
bit too all right
yeah i mean even for 1986
i mean you know you could cut it some
slack because it was 1986 and it's low
budget right um
but even by those standards
yeah
the monster is
it's not not great jason was big into
[ __ ] um hp hp lovecraft yeah he would
read lovecraft stuff
and
he was big into off-brand
horror
and this just seemed very off-brand to
us
but it also had like a feeling of
legitimacy
you know irish demons
you know
coming back coming up out of the ground
from underneath the stone and he was an
ancient warlord from the past you know
and uh
he was just [ __ ] [ __ ] up you know
and he was satanic
and what sold us on the thing is when it
was pissed on the priest and he's going
to baptize me you know like i just we're
like yeah this [ __ ] this [ __ ]
movie is awesome you know
because that was really going out there
and then the stained glass with the [ __ ]
stained glass with the [ __ ] monster
head in it and the weird puzzle
which in the day
it seemed like that was some that was
some mysterious [ __ ] you look at it now
there's not much to it
but back in the day you thought that was
like a nifty idea that laser beams
coming through the eyes of the [ __ ]
raw head wrecks inside the [ __ ]
stained glass window a stained glass in
the church and then when the sun comes
through it makes like a red laser that
the kitty can chase yeah
i
touching the tabernacle and getting
possessed we weren't really sure what
that meant
and i don't think we really understood
the end but i can't i understand the
ending now with like the sacred feminine
balancing it out
uh [ __ ] raw head
his head was raw because it was too hard
from all that testosterone see it's a
[ __ ] phallic symbol [ __ ] thing
that's what i think i think the whole
raw head rex was a [ __ ] phallic symbol
well yeah and the thing about it is that
if you had read the original story which
is actually very very good it's from uh
books of blood volume three yeah and if
you had seen the graphic novel that was
based on that story and had
a better design of the monster the
monster in the graphic novel and the way
that clive barker describes the monster
in the story is nothing
like not necessarily he kind of looks
like
i've seen a couple people point out they
think and i'm talking about the graphic
novel monster here not the movie monster
because we'll get into that but the
graphic novel monster you can look it up
like if you look up
you know rawhead rex graphic novel you
can see with the monster looks much much
better it's like much scarier
its body kind of looks like its body is
sort of like grayish blue and it kind of
looks a little bit like like from the
head down it kind of looks like pumpkin
head like he's just very like wiry and
thin he's like real real big like nine
or ten feet tall from the neck down yeah
and then it's head head down is the
whole body yeah that's the you know what
i mean
but then his head kind of looks like it
does and then he has kind of like fur
like around his shoulders kind of but
then his head is sort of like
brownish yellow gold sort of but it
looks kind of like the head of a penis
but it kind of looks like a moon too
like it's really big and round and it's
got like this really really wide mouth
and when he opens it there's like all
these big huge [ __ ] teeth and his
eyes are like really little and they're
red but they're like these little piggy
eyes and like a little like nose like
that and he's actually pretty cool
looking and this he just looks like a
pig pretty much
in this one like a razor i was reading a
review earlier and it said that the
monster in this looks like a cross
between
um
uh what do you call what was that
[ __ ] show oh it said he looks like a
power rangers villain crossed with a
member of gwar yeah he does kind of
because the thing about it is like and i
was thinking this too
um this occurred to me when we were
re-watching the movie i'm like why he's
supposed to be like a demigod or like a
demon yeah he's not a warlord or
anything like that he's a supernatural
creature he's a he's a demigod
so why would he be wearing clothes like
why would he look like a heavy metal
monster like why would he have a mullet
because it was for example yeah
why would he dress like he had like this
kind of it wasn't leather i don't think
but it was kind of like this thing and
it had like little um little animal
skulls like on it he looked like he
looked like a monster version of the
biker from uh raising arizona
i had the biker guy from raising here
to me except like with a monster head he
looked like blackie lawless from wasp
yeah
[Laughter]
i mean it's just so it's sad because
it's like this is such a good idea for a
story like the monster just looks so so
bad it's just kind of like but it's in a
way it kind of goes around and becomes
like kind of good again just because the
monster is so ludicrous
you can like you can see like the
monster's face it's just rubber like a
rubber mask and it doesn't move like it
doesn't really move
like the mouth shots it did i mean and
you know and the eyes just kind of like
they glow red and they kind of go like
that and they kind of look a little bit
googly yeah like and he looks a little
bit cross-eyed which you know that's not
really
not not really kind of like you know
leaning into the menace there he just
kind of looks real goofball
they did a couple of shots where they
clo where they did a close-up on the
face it's not moving somehow they
animated it so the eyes blinked
that's and it only only did it twice
but the rest of the time he's running
around it's obviously a [ __ ] big old
mask yeah and his mouth is just like
yeah it's not it's just going around
like that and sometimes in some shots
you can see the actor
inside his mouth yeah
[Laughter]
like if you look close yeah i mean they
didn't
have the the right person mate
making that costume but you know that
almost happened with predator
the first monster that they used in that
[ __ ] suck they took it out and put
the predator that you know and evidently
the predator that was in there was bad
like this you know
imagine that but um
i mean it didn't look like this but it's
as bad as this
it's about the uh
it it's not a bad movie i mean it's it's
it's bad in the way that uh
it was a movie that
felt a lot like other horror movies of
the 70s and the 80s yeah it did it was
part of a scene and for us
it was just a new one to watch it came
out we watched
you know and we just put that in the
pile with the rest of them like with
reanimator and [ __ ] from beyond and
all that it wasn't as good as those but
it was just another one to see
and you in certain when we watched him
when we were you know in high school we
really only focused on the scenes that
we liked that's what we remembered
the [ __ ] we didn't really like that much
we'd forget all about that yeah we just
remembered the [ __ ] that we liked about
it
i kind of feel like a lot of people do
that which is why sometimes people saw a
movie a long time ago and they're like
oh man that was so cool and then they
watch it again when they're older like
what the [ __ ] was i thinking because
they only remembered like one or two one
or two scenes that were awesome and then
the rest of it was like shitty
because i've had that happen too
yeah that's what it was but uh the
storytelling was actually uh pretty good
it was kind of standard um the acting
was
interesting standard
the acting was interesting what was
entertaining it was an irish movie
yeah even though the original story was
actually set in england like it was set
in a village but it was supposed to be
like right outside of london they moved
us to ireland i guess for tax purposes
it was an irish movie even though
like most of the main characters are
american
um or they're pretending to be american
yeah i'm not really getting know i don't
know if that guy really was american
the weird thing about like the guy that
plays like the main character yeah
howard holland back in england i guess
he's supposed to be american right
because he's over there yeah doing like
uh like a research project right um
and i'm guessing he's supposed to be but
for some reason he kind of sounded
american sometimes but then sometimes i
got the impression that i'm like that
sounds like a british actor trying to do
an american accent sometimes like on
some words i'm not sure i don't know
like
it was kind of like
the way a foreigner might imagine a new
york accent
sounds as well yeah because sometimes he
sounded like very very thickly new york
but then sometimes he just sounded kind
of like regular american and sometimes
it was just i don't know it was just a
very strange yeah it was a strange
performance yeah everybody in this gave
a really strange performance yeah um
really the only i mean some of them are
fine but it's like i liked the guy that
played um declan o'brien the the priest
that gets peed on yeah yeah because he
just like [ __ ] went for it he steals
the show actually and he he's just like
i'm just gonna chew all this scenery all
of it yeah and uh it was
it's like it's so awesome it's amazing
that guy's awesome cause like i said if
you're gonna have a monster he probably
like looked at the monster suit and he's
like okay this is like some schlocky b
movie i'm just gonna like roll with that
yeah whereas everybody else was kind of
trying to take it seriously i guess yeah
but i don't know but the thing about it
okay
so i i you you confirmed it though i
figured rawhead rawhead was supposed to
be a dick
yeah well he's supposed to be in the
original story
he is um a demigod
that uh he's like he represents the
negative embodiment of the male sex
drive yeah he's like ball
yeah he's that like um so he's kind of
like the male sex drive if unbound by
morality yeah so he's real into rape
uh you know real into like violence like
eating people and [ __ ] and just [ __ ]
[ __ ] up
yeah uh and i figured yeah and so and i
kind of feel like they didn't really get
that across in the movie and it would
have made more sense because at the end
of the movie like when he's quote
unquote sort of defeated kind of yeah by
the woman holding the fertility symbol
like the little statue of the pregnant
woman in the story that's much clearer
because it's made clear that the demon
is afraid of or either like afraid of or
weakened by or disgusted by
women who are pregnant and women who are
menstruating yeah uh so they kind of go
into that more in the story
uh which would have they probably should
have
done that in the movie more i kind of
the movie to me it's it sucks because
the story is so good and it's like such
a good idea
um and i really wish this is one of the
things i know everybody [ __ ] about
remakes but in this case i really think
one is justified and clyde barker has
wanted to do a remake because i don't
know like clive barker wrote the
screenplay for this
uh so it's pretty close to his
original story as far as the plot beats
go but he didn't direct it like this
other guy george pavlou directed it
and he also did another clive barker uh
adaptation called underworld uh which is
also sometimes called transmutations
clyde barker didn't like that one either
uh he was not a big fan of this
movie when it came out um he's like i
just wrote the screenplay and i don't
even think he went to the set when they
were making it and then he saw it
afterward and he's like oh no but um
there's a story that clive barker hated
this movie so much that he's like [ __ ]
it i'm only directing you know uh
adaptations of my work from now on and
then we got hellraiser which is awesome
but i don't think that's entirely true
um you know yeah
this movie is very remakeable it'd be
great they didn't um
in this one
like you said the main problem is that
they didn't do any setup
of the yin yang male female thing they
didn't go that much into the mythology
you had to figure it out on your own
yeah and they didn't give you much time
to do that i don't even remember that
as a kid so we didn't even pick up on it
no as i was watching it play out now as
an adult you know i know a lot more
about mythology i i instantly saw what
they were talking about yeah um
so
i got it but the average person wouldn't
have i don't think they would go and it
really doesn't and obviously it would
have hammered the point home more if the
monster looked more like he described it
i mean the monster he's not describing
like a walking dick necessarily
but the shape of its head kind of looks
like you know the the head of a penis
you don't even need to do that though
you can you can get away with it in
other ways to just make it look really
hyper masculine you could do that that'd
be enough
and then uh you're using
you're using artifacts that are real
hyper feminine looking to defeat him so
you would know and you could also just
have people do some exposition in the
film you know what i mean that he's
that he's that he's just so [ __ ]
manly that he's got to be kept out of
control you know that kind of [ __ ] well
i mean like i said they did kind of do
little things like when he gets released
at the beginning
the kind of monolith that is presumably
like keeping him under the earth like
the last time he was defeated like you
know the like the church windows say
it kind of looks like a dick it looks
like a big earth dick like sticking out
of the ground so that's kind of what
that is and like i said they kind of do
a little bit of a thing where
one of the people that he is uh you know
terrorizing he goes and like tears open
that woman's shirt and then sees that
she's pregnant and he's like you know
what i mean and backs away but you're
not really sure they don't make it super
clear
they're like what does he not want to
kill a baby or is he because because the
monster's face doesn't move you can't
tell
why he didn't kill that woman like he
kills everybody else another thing that
we remembered and i remember we were
mentioning it
uh
at the time that we saw it
meeting steve and
jason we noticed that there weren't any
cute girls in it
it's just that guy and his wife and the
family and the priests it could be
unusual yeah horror movie of that era
uh that
there's almost always some kind of a
teenage damsel in distress type
type deal well and
keep the young guys watching it you
didn't there wasn't even a tit shot
until like the end yeah because remember
because you were saying why did we even
watch this there's no tits in it but
then like at the end yeah there's a very
gratuitous right like thing where the
monster is killing somebody that's like
oh there's the tits oh yeah right yeah
uh we know this is an 80s movie but the
thing about it too is that it's a clive
barker story and clive barker's stories
if you haven't read them are hyper hyper
sexual yeah so you would think there
would be like a lot more smut in the
because that's all that's his thing man
it's apparently he loves that kind of
thing since ireland maybe they were
[ __ ] limited in what they could do
maybe so i'm not yeah law is kind of
like blue laws that's true yeah so which
is weird because like i said there this
original story is not set in ireland i
mean i don't think it made that much of
a difference the original story is that
in england but
i don't really think it made that much
they probably just did it because it was
cheaper some places you can't film
nudity especially back in those days
yeah permits because because you'd have
to call it a porn movie yeah so you
couldn't do it yeah i remember hearing
[ __ ] about that you couldn't film you
couldn't film a movie in mississippi
that had any nudity in it yeah i heard
that and maybe alabama too i think like
because because remember for a long time
like alabama you couldn't sell like sex
toys or anything like that
it's sharia law down there
basically it was for well for us it's up
there
[Laughter]
it's sharia law there basically pretty
much
but yeah can we let's talk a little bit
about
i another thing i don't love i mean
obviously the thing that everybody
brings up when they talk about this
movie is like how stupid the monster
looks but can we also talk about the
family that's at the center of this i
really don't like
the
i don't know if it's the actors if they
just didn't have any chemistry with one
another if they just didn't have i don't
know it was just like a really strange
dynamic they had going on i kind of got
the feeling that i mean they kind of set
it up where the dude like the main guy
he's gone over to ireland and they've
been there for like a month i think he
says because he's doing some kind of
research project about fertility cults
or something like that so he's going all
around ireland and he's dragging his
whole family around with him and his
wife is obviously like not super happy
about this because she's like
real aggro
but the thing that field said that i'm
right
about what probably about ireland and
being being able to what what kind of
licensing well no because that's been
there a long time so that must have been
something from like a long time ago
but um just saw that that's only two
comments down see that's you're [ __ ]
me up man you [ __ ] say [ __ ] oh y'all
say [ __ ] y'all need to be punished you
say you don't give me goddamn context
calm down tom yeah get mad right
what's the matter with you it said man
are you are you hopped up on the
goofballs yeah no no
i took an injection oh that explains it
that explains it yeah yeah so i don't
love so so there's a really weird like
dynamic between
the dad and the mom and it's like they
kind of try to be sexy with one another
but it just comes off as like really
awkward and creepy also the kids kind of
the little girl is fine but that son is
really a douche and he gets killed
like but spoiler alert by the monster
they don't really show it unfortunately
um you know hey i know it's the 80s but
it's kind of like
maybe that was another thing they
couldn't show it's like we can't they
just imply that the kid died because
we're sitting there going wait did the
kid die i can't remember because all
they show is like his bloody
you know comic book and his shoe and
then like you know like the monster is
like standing there by the car with his
blood all over his face and he's like
there were certain things that you
couldn't see
and it didn't have anything to do with
the ratings sometimes
if it had to do with uh video video uh
visa video distribution of certain
things yeah where it wasn't illegal it's
just the distributors didn't want to
didn't want to just yeah
so
and it always depended on the when and
where you're talking about so may have
been that they didn't want to
show the kid get killed because it would
have changed the ratings or the pissed
off a distributor so they did [ __ ] like
that maybe they filmed it and cut it out
yeah because it's really just like
implied and then it's weird because
after the kid gets killed which they
don't really show
then
it seems like like the family is sort of
upset about it but not as upset as you'd
think they'd be yeah yeah yeah you know
what i mean someone's like louder they
just yeah they're just like my son is
dead and i'm just like you think that
they would go through like a lot more
grief and then like the mom and the
daughter just like yeah that's super sad
i mean they're like man that wasn't my
favorite kid anyway i got another one
you know what i mean it's like it was
almost like that like they tried to
pretend like they were upset but they
weren't really upset yeah but i don't
know there's a lot of good stuff i like
about this movie i like the mythology
behind it i like the story
but
it's just i kind of feel like this was
yeah the execution of it was really
half-assed most of the problems that was
the monster
yeah the the monster they went through
all this trouble making this movie
and they didn't make multiple monsters
for different shots
you got to have one monster that runs
around you have another monster that for
close-ups like [ __ ] facial
expressions
and biting people and stuff and they
didn't do that really it was just one
although maybe in that one shot it was a
like the eyes did blink maybe that was a
different
mask but it wasn't very it wasn't good
enough
you know yeah it just wasn't and i mean
anybody would have known i mean yeah it
was 1986 but there's all kinds of [ __ ]
out by holy [ __ ] i mean look at some of
the movies they did in the early 80s
yeah look at predator yeah
look at the thing
uh pumpkin head may have been out by
then uh pumpkin head i think came out in
88. okay so it was like a couple of
years ago you had [ __ ] alien and
aliens
yeah i mean look at that
so i mean yeah they probably couldn't
afford [ __ ] stan winston or you know
tom savini or anything like that but god
damn no they had other kids they had
people that could do that that could go
in and do that you just needed no excuse
you just needed a
monster that had a fully articulated
face
and
and you had to shoot it the right way so
it's obviously not a guy
in a [ __ ] costume running around
looking like guar
yeah like guard
running around it looks like
that it just it really does look like a
dude in a [ __ ] suit running out in
the middle of a bunch of trailers with a
bunch of other people right up next to
it running around just the way that it's
shot it's not convincing at all
that's not how you yeah it's very
clearly a guy in a robbery clearly
the the lead singer of guar
[Laughter]
very clearly he's even acting like rock
concerts yeah like the way he's like
holding arms out and he's like he's got
a mullet it's just kind of like why why
would they think that was a good idea
kind of like they were like man people
aren't really going to take this
seriously let's just have fun with this
it's almost like they weren't taking it
seriously well obviously they weren't
because i think they were like well
nobody's gonna take it seriously if
anybody came in that was actually like
taking the [ __ ] seriously like came in
and saw that monster be like absolutely
not you were fired let's get another
crew in here and let's do this over
four throw down points out and aliens
only cost 18 million dollars
yeah that's what i mean you don't need a
lot of money if you know what you're
doing and honestly if they were going to
go with this goofy-ass looking monster
at least like just shoot it in the dark
for christmas click don't show it the
thing about it is that the movie is so
or the monster is so dorky
and they just never fail to show it in
broad daylight like all the time they
show it like two or three minutes into
the film like jumping out of the hole in
the ground like
it looks like a [ __ ] wrestling guy
tammy says she hasn't seen it in a long
time she wants to see it again it's look
it's not that bad it's a fun watch it is
fun to watch
it does it is kind of nostalgic yeah uh
it does kind of it's one of the movies
from that era
that you watch it you go oh yeah i
remember when movies were like this
and you just kind of go back into that
mode i don't know if a younger person
would get it um but they might just
think it's like ludicrous which it is it
is ludicrous it's great in the way
halloween three is great if you
understand what i'm talking about it's
like that
yeah but halloween three is much better
but halloween three is a much better
kind of like that
well no
i'm trying to think of like what the
equivalent of this would be what else is
this like
i don't know it's hard because the thing
about it well it it kind of occupies
that space where because you know how
like some movies are just so ridiculous
and they're just like [ __ ] it and but
it's just like wildly entertaining
because they're just having fun with it
this kind of straddles the line between
it's ridiculous but also they're kind of
taking it seriously so it's kind of like
you can't really take it either way
like it's not so over the top ludicrous
that it's
hilarious i mean it kind of is but then
it's like not so
i don't know but then it's not so good
that it's i don't know it just takes
itself too seriously to really be
that entertaining but it is still kind
of entertaining but i'm sure that it's
they didn't mean for it to be funny in
that particular way
i mean i'm sure that the guy that was
like a german stuntman i think the guy
in that suit like that big dude yeah um
i think this is the only movie he was in
but his fault though yeah it wasn't his
fault that the suit looked like that he
didn't make it yeah and uh it wasn't his
fault that they shot it that way
yeah you should have shot that thing
to leave a lot of mystery with it really
what they were talking about is pumpkin
head
basically
yeah and a lot of people like a lot of
reviews i've read of this have pointed
out that the the monster in pumpkin head
looks a lot like what clive barker
described in the story than this monster
does yeah so they could have gone into
more direction like that where he's just
like this big tall wiry yeah like
looking thing with a big ass dick
hanging down and he's got like his head
that kind of looks like i mean the
monster looks cool in the graphic novel
i think had this thing
looked as good as pumpkin head
they would have taken this movie more
seriously i think and it would have the
actors and [ __ ] maybe
and the crew probably would have taken
the movie a little bit more seriously
and it probably would have turned out
pretty good it's i think they were just
going like yeah this is some schlock
let's let's let's have fun
it has a kind of a fun element to it
i just i just don't think they're really
taking it seriously it it's it's it's
almost kind of like there's trying to
make it a little bit funny or something
kind of like in the way that they did
reanimator the tone is kind of like that
but the thing about it was that
reanimator
was good was trying to be
a dark comedy yeah this movie i kind of
feel like some of the people thought
they were in a dark comedy and some of
the people thought they were in a horror
movie and no one was on the same page
exactly that's kind of what
that's kind of how it comes across
because some of the people seem like
they're trying to like this is a serious
scary movie and then some people like
the guy playing the priest is just like
going hell for leather and just being as
ridiculous as possible okay i got it you
got it i got it
this is the equivalent this is the
monster equivalent of the old [ __ ]
70s classic late 70s early 80s classic
shock waves
oh yeah with the the nazi [ __ ] zombie
yeah soldiers shock waves remember that
it's like we saw that not too long ago
did we review it yeah no no i don't
think we did maybe we did i thought we
were i like shots because i'm pretty
sure we saw it like that too long this
is kind of like a goofier version of
that but i would say
production quality and everything it's
about to say about like shock waves
blurred dude says it's like the giant
claw level goofiness yeah
i mean
yeah because the giant claw
if you guys are that was like from the
50s oh with the flying bird with the big
like bert like turkey
whatever the [ __ ] it was and it had like
the googly eyes it's kind of like that
yeah i mean it probably cost a little
bit more to make but probably not much
more
yeah if rawhead rex was a 50s giant
monster movie it would be that one giant
claw yeah yeah that's that's a good
that's a good call that's that's good
it's a 50s version yeah yeah if you guys
haven't seen go go look at pictures of
the giant claw like the monster from
that you'll see where we're talking yeah
the funny thing is you know about the
giant claws it was a standard 50s giant
monster movie pretty standard until you
saw that monster and then everybody just
busted it out loud i think even in the
50s they busted out laughing
and their and their standards were way
lower yeah you know what i mean and
they're like you're kidding right i mean
okay
yeah the giant claw was weird is that
they spent a lot of money making that
thing and they thought it was going to
be great i think isn't it isn't it isn't
that the story behind it
i don't know like we maybe we should
review that actually because it's like
because they did a lot of cool shots
where they had giant claws coming down
trying to grab people and
wasn't trying to grab an airplane or a
jeep but
it had some unique shots for the time
where a giant monster tries to grab
people
and things from what i remember
or tries to tear apart an airplane while
it's flying
which is ahead of its time and they
spent a bunch of mo if i remember they
spent a bunch of money on that monster
and then when they delivered it they're
like what that's it that's what we
[ __ ] bought that they well we gotta
go we want our money back
[Laughter]
yeah
yeah blair and i said uh i think giant
claw almost had ray harryhausen yeah i'd
heard that which uh obviously would have
been
much
better much better
uh
they would have [ __ ] paid him instead
of bought that [ __ ] marionette yeah
and then they're like well now we're out
of money and we have to use it the
japanese [ __ ] just [ __ ] blew
[ __ ] giant claw out of the water with
rodan because rodan i remember seeing
that as a kid [ __ ] loved it the big
flying pterodactyl
although you know don't get too because
japan also had the gamer movies and they
had some pretty silly monsters in those
[ __ ] camera movies what was the one
what was that one monster that whose
head looked like a knife oh and then
like his little lower jaw was like
triangular and when he shot it down
[ __ ]
no baragon was the one that kind of
looked like he was he was four-legged
okay the one with the knife head
was it zegra
zebra zigra probably something like that
i can't remember i've seen so many of my
camera
but he's like and he could like cut like
other monsters like into little stakes
which i thought was kind of cool
i was too young to realize that there's
a difference between like the touhou
ones and then that than that company
yeah but you look at it now the touhou
ones were a lot better because they were
smashing model buildings yeah they
didn't have model buildings in the
camera ones they were too expensive they
didn't have some but they just weren't
all that good and the camera movies
always had a kenny yeah there's a candy
running around get him cabaret
little kids
booty shorts
little boys with booty shorts and
[ __ ] baseball caps
yeah oh my god ridiculous pat hatfield
said transmutations is the real
disappointment of the early barker
adaptations yeah that's the same
director as this one um i don't think
i've seen it honestly it's and i'm it's
really a shame because i love
clive barker's written work but movie
adaptations of his stuff
most of them just really aren't that
good i mean hell raiser's good candy
man's good midnight mate train was good
um
other than that not really a lot of them
stand out all that much i think the
thing about it is that if you're going
to make
i mean if you're going to make a clive
barker if you're going to adapt a clyde
barker story you have to go all in i
mean hellraiser worked because it went
all in it was like super gory it had all
the s m the weird sexual [ __ ] that's in
the story you can't like
battlerize any of clive barker's stories
so like i said if you're gonna remake
rawhead rex
then go all in with the penis monster
thing
you know what i mean go all in with like
the the sexual stuff go all in with that
uh that male energy folklore and i think
it would be like a lot better
pat's mad that i compared raw head rex
to shock waves he wants to explain that
i no they're they're well shock waves
wasn't that with the monsters there
wasn't even monsters in that was it it
was just like guys
german uniforms that were just kind of
like pale yeah right they were they came
out here walking across the water what i
was talking about is that i said that
that the two movies
have a similar production quality i
would say or no no i'd say like a
similar kind of not production quality
but yeah
like like the budgets would be similar
it's about like that i think i don't
even know how much i don't know shock
waves might have been even cheaper to
make it looks like it would yeah because
the thing about shock waves is that it
had a lot of padding yeah a lot of pads
a lot of people like walking around yeah
the story was okay though the idea for
shockwaves would have been really good
uh it is good it just didn't quite
i liked the movie though um they had
peter cushing in it he's [ __ ] you
know that's really one of the reasons to
see that movie yeah i mean i'll watch
pretty much anything yeah
yeah i mean
but there's something about shockwaves
to where i can go back and watch it
and enjoy it
i don't know why
it just has a certain tone to it yeah
and knowing that it's like a florida
movie that's also like a thing about i
was like oh yeah that's up the road it's
it's a southern horror movie
with peter cushing in it yeah that's
[ __ ] pretty wild man
lyrdo says oh isn't wasn't that film
just up above daytona
i thought it was shot like uh
either south
florida or
over on the west coast i thought i don't
remember
yeah west coast i think is right west
coast yeah i think and um
it was by an old spanish hotel there was
a band and then
yeah probably gone now probably torn
down yeah did i look for it i thought it
was like around miami or something okay
or west palm or somewhere but like i
said it was a while back i think i tried
to look for that
yeah that's why i'm saying that we
reviewed it not too long ago because i
know we did uh research about where that
was it must have just been in the last
six months because i think we watched it
here like in this house yeah
i think i did find it
yeah we did i just can't wear that hotel
i thought it was somewhere around my
head it was funny yeah what was funny is
that if i recall correctly because we
reviewed it or we at least talked about
it um
when i went back to try to find where
that hotel was
um
in the in the day that they filmed shock
waves that was kind of like in the
middle of nowhere like a resort away
from everything else but now i think
it's almost in damn middle of the city
today because it's sprawl you know
sprawled out
florida's
becoming suburban sprawl in a lot of
those places but back in those days it
was like something out of movie the
island you know
not much there
tropical paradise [ __ ]
lyrido says the monster that i was
trying to think of from the gamer movie
was giron that's right
yeah year on zegra was the one that kind
of looked like wasn't zegor the one that
kind of looked like the rodeo just lumpy
now he just looked like kind of a lump
of hair or something i don't remember
was that the one with the was that the
one with the kid that looked like
richard burton
and then
richard where they go in the spaceship
and there's those two women that are in
there that are creepy and like give them
doughnuts don't look like an
ankylosaurus with a with a [ __ ]
bull's head on it remember that had
spikes on the side of him and he had a
[ __ ] tail see that was baragon that
was bearagon i'm pretty sure that was
why are we trying
but yeah so
like i said of all the movies that
they're remaking i wish that they would
not like remake movies that were
perfectly good to start with but i wish
if they're gonna remake something remake
this yeah because the original source
material is great
uh we have the technology nowadays to do
it
and you know you could probably get away
with a lot more
nowadays uh if you were gonna make it
and you wouldn't even have to like
you know have it in the theater like
anything like that you could just go
right to streaming if you wanted to
um i just really kind of think that this
is and like i said clyde barker wants to
do it too like he definitely wants
because i think that you know he thinks
the dude kind of [ __ ] it up
uh which which he did it is kind of
[ __ ] up the thing about it like i said
there's good things about it i like the
mythology behind it i kind of like some
of the [ __ ] but
the monster looks ridiculous the actors
are
not great and are kind of like all over
the place like they're in different
movies and i don't like the end the end
seems like really like anti-climactic
you know what i mean um this movie could
be fixed though it's oh yeah it's it's a
good idea it's a good story
um
actually the movie couldn't be fixed
this movie needs to be re-shot there
used to be another one of these
and uh it has to be as good as pumpkin
head um when it comes to special effects
yeah because look how good that monster
looked although like i said i'm pretty
sure stan winston did that it was kind
of like you know he's the man oh they
got young guys that could probably do
but yeah i mean now and honestly if they
did it and it looked kind of like if
they did rawhead rex and it looked more
like
the monster from the um from the graphic
novel
they could do that as a practical effect
because it's still like kind of humanoid
yeah i'd do it practical um
you know i think that would be really
cool maybe they could get like guillermo
del toro or something like that and do
it it's somebody talk i would it needed
to talk if you asked me i think in the
story i can't remember if it talked in
the story but in the yeah in the movie
it was just kind of like a big
like a big monster brute like a gorilla
basically yeah i think in the story i
don't remember if it could talk but it
was for sure like intelligent yeah and
it could learn
you know what i mean like what
like uh it learned how to use fire and
it did [ __ ] like that like because it
had been asleep for like a long time i
guess yeah but it was
you
the story kind of like went into its
thought processes but i don't remember
if it talked or not i don't think it did
but it was like for sure smarter than
what they showed in the movie because
like i said it just looked like a
[ __ ]
it looked like it looked like wwf
to be honest or like a guar show and the
way that it was shot
just was not
i don't know if it was the lighting yeah
it was very flat yeah it was no mystery
to it at all it was very flat like there
was no
i kind of feel like a lot of the shots
didn't have any like visual interest
there's a shot where he comes jumping up
out of the water and there's like a
castle behind him or something or a
church behind him and [ __ ] lightning
coming down he's going
it's like something out of a damn uh
[Laughter]
it's basically like something out of
[ __ ] incredible hulk like the
incredible television a lot of it kind
of looked like really cheesy like death
metal yeah music videos yeah like from
the 80s which is maybe that's why we
partner partially liked it because he
had kind of like a like i said kind of
like this weird medieval looking
[ __ ] heavy metal outfit and all right
i was like i i can't take seriously a
monster that wears boots and has a
mullet yeah he had a boots huh i mean
yeah
he's a demon why i was like why does he
have clothes on having cool clothes why
is he closed
like the one he didn't have clothes in
the story
and then in the graphic novel he was
just like he's just like a monster he
doesn't have anything in hell they got
clothes
they got clothes he stopped at goodwill
on the way
kind of dressed like the kurgan from
[ __ ] highlander
yeah like i said he kind of reminded me
of uh of like i said the biker from
raising arizona yeah he's like the
kruger like with all the little skulls
and stuff like that like on his sleeve
he had a head look at a crossing a horse
and a pig
well yeah yeah or and a kind of a
gorilla and a gorilla a little bit of a
gorilla yeah but i think that was like
and he had like all these teeth and
stuff but like i said the mouth didn't
move it wasn't scary and it was just
like as soon as you saw it you just like
bust up laughing well it's like
something you say from [ __ ] like uh
power rangers
yeah that's what like i said somebody
said it looked like cross between a
power rangers villain like a member of
guard
actually the members of guar are
probably scarier
they're probably scarier looking you've
seen the manager aguirre
he's got a huge [ __ ] wig like at the
huge oh yeah yeah
he'll [ __ ]
sit in there and [ __ ] talk to you
about [ __ ] what happened on 911 and
911 conspiracy theories and [ __ ]
i i saw guard a bunch of times back in
the day
manager is a [ __ ] suit is a [ __ ]
cut as a cop is a character i think
there is no i think there are no
original members to guar and i don't
think yeah i haven't followed them i
don't think they're they don't think
there has been original members to gore
for a long time i think it's just an
ever rotating
stack well that's kind of the nice thing
about like dressing up in costumes is
that anybody could be in there yeah i
think they get new names though i think
i don't know
well you got to give them credit they
committed to that stick yeah i mean you
know yeah not all at the same time one
at a time
there's i mean their shows used to be
like really really entertaining but like
i said i haven't been to one like a
really long time i've never seen a
poster in detroit for it they had
[ __ ] nailed nailed everywhere one of
the one and [ __ ] one of them one of
the characters called balzac the
magnificent yeah that's right balzac was
yeah i'm going what the [ __ ] is this and
one of them was a girl and her titties
were out
with a i don't know if they were real
titties or fake titties
but she had a head and a [ __ ] thing
and she's wearing and and she had hair
i think she had a mask on
with [ __ ] i think her titties were
out big old titties but they were
probably big rubber titties
yeah you know how guar was you know just
funny can i make you a shirt that says
big rubber tip big rubber too will you
wear it
you wear it it just
they did those like repediograph [ __ ]
posters back in those days yeah yeah and
they were just hooking up everywhere did
you go up and like smell them
[Laughter]
no that's what they used to do with it
that was that was
i
mimeography
that's what they give them to you like
they had one in the office at the school
and they would like run off all the yeah
they had a smell too yeah i didn't know
and everybody as soon as they passed
them out everybody everybody pick them
up go
because like the ink was like smelling
really funny no they just had them um i
don't know i thought
i just saw that in detroit they had them
um
that was back when they would make a
[ __ ] ton of flyers and staple them to
[ __ ] telephone poles yeah you don't
see that anymore
you do kind of like in big cities you do
well you know you just go on [ __ ]
instagram or facebook and [ __ ] post
links yeah it's just that you don't
really have to you don't have to you
don't have to like pay to print all that
[ __ ] out yeah
litter everywhere and it doesn't reach
as many people and it doesn't target
market it yeah see
it's kind of better all right better now
it's better all around yeah and graphic
design is so much better now but those
old [ __ ] repediograph
graphics they looked kind of cool that
just one color it was real rough low-res
yeah kind of had an underground kind of
[ __ ] feel to it well even like a lot
of bands and stuff nowadays try to uh
replicate that yeah that look you know
just because they like that the way that
that looked all right jenny do we have
enough of uh raw head rex yeah i guess
we do so yeah this movie is on uh what
is it on is it on shutter did we watch
it on shutter ah i can't remember if
it's on shutters i think it was on
shutter maybe i think it was on shutter
it might be like other places too it's
like it's not a great movie but it's you
know if you want to like have some
drinks or get high or something like
that and like watch the [ __ ] and like
laugh at the monster when it pops out
um have some kind of drinking game like
for whenever the monster like does some
heavy metal [ __ ] maybe but this is one
that i'd really really like to see
redone because i kind of liked it i like
it too but it's ridiculous it's a
ridiculous movie yeah um but i'd really
really like to see this redone because i
really really like the original story
yeah and uh i'd honestly just really
like to see clive barker done right the
way i imagine his stories there i know
they're hard to do because he's his
shit's way out there but it's a good
story yeah yeah yeah all right so we
will be back tomorrow
uh talking about i think we're going to
be talking about needful things of the
stephen king adaptation because we just
watched that last night so we will see
you guys again tomorrow evening bye